makes me really happy when actors I
admire get behind the lens and start to
explore that realm and also help get
projects they're passionate about off
the ground and I'm curious for you given
all your acting experience how has that
influenced the casting process on your
movie is there anything that you've
experienced in an actor director
relationship that now you're looking for
and actors you're going to work with as
the Director
um
I should have said the movie The Pack
it's called a pacquia it's an ensemble
piece so it's uh it's obviously about
finding the right group and the right um
chemistry and uh
um
I
my goal is to cast people I love and
some of my close friends and uh on
it's been interesting being on this side
of a casting process it's been I've
learned a lot it's been sometimes it's
quite disheartening with in terms of
people's value and
um some of those conversations are uh
a bit
um with financiers and everything it's
like
when you start to understand that model
of foreign territories of someone's
value and and someone you think is
amazing and you think would mean a lot
for financing doesn't and then someone
the opposite means a lot who you don't
get why
um so it is that on
what Miranda said
I think
um you're gonna have to make a lot of
compromises but you got to choose your
battles and figure out when it comes to
Casting obviously um
it's it's crucial to for me to
do with the with the the the actors I
want to work with and and find that
chemistry and that group uh otherwise
um
it's not worth it for me I'm not uh I'm
pretty content being
quote-unquote just an actor so it's not
that I feel like I have to segue into
directing
um
I was on high on painkillers and had
hubris and thought I could direct this
for a second and maybe that was a
mistake uh
but um
um we'll see we'll see